Student:  Okay,
so today Professor Rae is not
going to be here and so we're
going to watch two videos
instead,
one of him and second one is of
Paul Collier talking a little
bit about his book,
but also about recent research
that he's done,
especially on governments and
commodities.
We're going to start with the
first video and then go straight
into the Paul Collier video;
so enjoy.
Prof: Hi there.
As you know I'm in Washington
today,
and Jim Alexander has been kind
enough to preside over the
Monday class,
and I want to get in twenty
minutes or so of background
thoughts taking us from the
SELCO case,
where the question was how to
organize the distribution of
distributed electrical
generating to bottom billion
areas of India.
From that very specific set of
questions to the much larger
question about understanding the
plight of the world's bottom
billion,
and the available strategies
for trying to be helpful to
them.
The main text for this class
and the next is Paul Collier's
Bottom Billion,
which is, while not a page
turning thriller like White
Tiger,
is a very solid,
serious, and substantial piece
of scholarship by somebody who
has been engaged both with the
best of growth economics as a
scholar,
and with the practical work of
the World Bank,
where he was head of research
for a good long time.
The default assumption in
thinking about the bottom
billion is to begin with the
world demographic transition and
the thought that most of these
people are the products of stage
two and stage three
demographies;
where birthrates were vastly
higher than death rates,
and so you had a huge surge in
population and you found--
and many people in those
societies found themselves in
the same predicament as the
protagonist in White
Tiger, as being one of way
too many candidates for every
job and having little or no
market power,
and consequently,
little or no income.
Collier's take is to say,
"Well let's just grow
incomes."
It's not a bad approach,
and he's perfectly aware of the
objections I'm going to make to
it in the next few minutes,
but let's just catalog what it
means.
The gross domestic product is
at once too broad and too
narrow, as a measure of value
generated by the economy.
For example,
if a housekeeper and her
employer,
or his, marry one another and
he or she continues to keep the
house but now on the basis of a
spousal relationship the cash
goes away and the value is
deducted from the GDP,
while in fact,
nothing has much changed.
Or suppose a crime wave hits a
society and enormous damage is
done to property by crime,
it requires repair;
those repairs get recorded in
GDP and can easily be mistaken
for an improvement in the
condition of people living
there.
Further, people buy better
locks, video cameras,
perhaps even weapons,
and those too are recorded as
improvements,
when in fact they really aren't
improvements.
Or take disease.
A--one society is relatively
healthy and has relatively lower
medical expenses than the other,
yet the second,
the one with the high medical
expenses,
would be accounted as better
off.
Finally, to get just how
mechanical this measure is,
if for any reason we were
prepared,
the government say,
was prepared to pay people to
dig holes and then fill them
back up with the same dirt and
pay them a salary for that,
we would have increased GDP.
Those are ways in which the
measure is too inclusive.
There are others ways in which
it is not inclusive enough.
It doesn't include--the saying
"The best things in life
are free,"
well that may not be entirely
true,
but some of the good things in
life are free,
and those need to be measured
in an accounting of how well off
a society is.
The leading substitute measured
these days for GDP per capita is
the human development index as
put forward by the World Bank
and parallel institutions,
which gives--which takes GDP
per capita as one part of the
story,
adds to it longevity,
and then supplements that by
adding a measure of education so
you get a somewhat broader
measure that captures the surge
we see in Hans Rosling's
wonderful data animation as
lives become longer and
prosperity greater.
So one thing to do is just
tinker with the measure.
There's a second set of issues
that have to do with the value
of income.
I've got some childlike
drawings here to share with you.
If we represent the dollar
income of Mr. A on the
horizontal axis and of Ms.
B on the vertical axis,
then GDP for these two people
is calculated just by adding the
one to the other with no
attention to the distribution
between them,
so that all the points on this
indifference curve would
correspond to the same GDP as
one another,
and all the points on this
indifference curve would
likewise so correspond.
Well that's okay,
there's nothing wrong with
that, except if you want to
infer from it the value shared
by A and B in the use of that
income.
A generally accepted hypothesis
is that the value of income,
and economists would use a term
utility,
let me just stick with
value--the value of income first
increases and then decreases at
the margin,
so that you get an S shaped
curve like this.
On the horizontal axis we have
how much income people get,
and on the vertical axis how
much value they derive from it.
Now imagine down here around
point A where people have
precious little income,
so little that they cannot feed
and clothe, and lodge
themselves.
Well think of a setting like an
American city and imagine
doubling your income,
annual income,
from $25 to $50.
Well that would move you a
little ways along the horizontal
axis but it wouldn't lift you up
the vertical axis because it's
not going to make a difference
until you get to some threshold
where you actually begin to get
increasing returns from rising
incomes,
as in the zone I've labeled B
here.
Then eventually incomes like
Richard Medley,
whom we met a month ago or
Paolo Zanonni,
who we'll meet in a couple of
weeks,
at their incomes the--so wide a
range of material needs are
already satisfied that the
marginal dollar gets less and
less valuable.
The implication of this for the
relationship between GDP per
capita on the one side and a
judgment of how well a society
is doing on the other is that
there's--
we should probably have some
egalitarian bias in the way we
interpret the numbers.
Where most people get to the
level that I'm pointing at here,
where the diminution of
marginal value really sets in,
where most people get to that,
that's kind of where you want
to be,
and Collier's emphasis on the
bottom billion responds to that.
The SELCO project,
for example,
which we saw a moment--
saw--well actually I'm speaking
just an hour after class,
which we saw in Wednesday's
class, is aimed at trying to
bring people up that steep part
of the curve,
maybe not very far but a little
ways,
by judiciously providing the
opportunity to purchase electric
light or electric power for such
other purposes as running a
sewing machine or preparing
goods of some kind for sale.
The common sense response to
this S curve is to pay special
attention to people who are near
its bottom and try to find ways
to help them push themselves up
the curve.
Now as a sidebar let me just
mention John Rawls,
who published in 1971 a classic
book,
a book that will be read
hundreds of years from now,
I imagine, called A Theory
Of Justice,
and Rawls asked people to
imagine that they were behind
what he called a veil of
ignorance,
and the idea of the veil of
ignorance is roughly that you
have no idea who you are.
It's a little like Adam Smith's
device in Theory Of Mortal
Sentiments.
But the question is,
if you had no idea who you were
before we set up the basic
institutions for a country,
or for the world if we think of
it on a global scale,
what would be your way of
structuring alternative
arrangements so that you could
find one that you thought was
best from--
for you from behind this veil
of ignorance and on which you
could agree with everyone else
behind the same veil?
His idea, stated way too
simply, is that you should
maximize the welfare of the
least advantaged group in
society.
The intuition is that that
group would be unskilled labor;
and that doesn't mean that you
should knock down inequalities
necessarily.
Indeed, if allowing bankers,
engineers,
and entrepreneurs to reap
substantial and very unequal
benefits from their work will
ultimately read down to the
benefit of this unskilled labor
stratum,
then that's great.
A Rawlsian picture of the
indifference curves which before
utilitarianism just run at minus
45ยบ here,
Rawls' are L shaped,
and so if we're here,
so that this person is way
better off than this person,
we try to move to a higher
indifference curve from the
point of view of the less
advantaged person;
and symmetrically here we try
to move in this direction,
so that the L shaped
indifference curves,
if there were just two people
in the society would drive us to
seek the highest one,
and it would have a powerful
middle-of-the-road bias to it,
but it wouldn't have so
powerful an egalitarian kick
that it would knock down
equality to an extent which hurt
even the less skilled parts of
the workforce.
Societies--and we know
societies that have reached that
level, in my judgment Castro's
Cuba is just such a case and I
know it fairly well;
North Korea,
which I know much less well,
appears to be such a case.
Okay so that's all by way of
background,
and now I just want to talk
rather briefly about the
introductory series of traps in
Collier's book,
and the traps are his way of
summarizing things that can go
very wrong for a country and put
it way behind the rest of the
world in economic growth.
Now as background,
Collier is really thinking
about what we would call
"emerging market
countries."
He's not thinking about
Germany, Japan,
Canada, or the states.
He's thinking about India,
Bangladesh,
Kenya, Zimbabwe,
Bolivia, and Mexico,
countries which are just
finishing the world demographic
transition,
and are relatively late
entrants as full players in
capitalist development.
The majority of them--and
Collier gives very little stress
to this,
and he probably should give
more--the majority of these
countries were colonial sites
for European powers,
and India is just such a case,
for example--
and the British Empire was
enormous.
Other countries were subject to
the Dutch,
the French, and other--and the
Spanish,
and the Spanish actually are
quite important,
European powers which treated
them as subordinate economies
and structured their governments
to the advantage of the
metropolitan country.
Trap one may be,
be a colonial site,
and be set back by it.
The other side to that story is
that the colonial powers
sometimes left something good
behind.
The extraordinary quality of
technical education in India,
for example,
is in part an outgrowth of
British education and the
systematic inculcation of
British educational values.
Wouldn't want to go too far
stressing that,
but it's there somewhere.
Okay so the Collier traps;
the first one is what he calls
a conflict trap,
and according to him 73% of the
bottom billion live in countries
which are now in civil wars or
have recently been in civil
wars.
That's a stunning number,
and the world which occupies
the front page of every major
newspaper--
Somalia, Iraq,
the incredible mess in
Afghanistan,
many other less dramatic cases,
these are all countries where
civil strife has defined life to
a considerable degree in let's
say the last twenty-five years.
Well the--Collier spends some
time asking the causes of that.
He rejects the common sense
popular explanation is ethnic
conflict.
He says that ethnic conflict is
actually quite a lot less
important than simple poverty.
That countries with very low
GDP per capita are greatly--
at much greater risk of civil
war than countries with higher
GDP per capita,
and that countries with growing
GDP are more secure than those
with static GDP,
particularly static GDP at a
low level.
Not much news in that but it's
actually very important because
if you think about the logic of
capital development--
capitalist development,
and you take either the Coase
Theorem or de Soto's development
of the Coase Theorem seriously,
which I do and I urge you to,
it's built on the foundation of
the Westphalia nation state
system,
which came into being in the
middle of the seventeenth
century.
Where civil wars are still in
progress that system isn't
there;
a civil war is indicative of a
failed state,
and a failed state can't
perform the capitalizing
functions of government which
are so central to the story de
Soto tells us,
and about which I think he is
very right.
The palliatives for this are
not obvious.
One thing we've pretty much
learned is that third party
interventions in civil wars,
by and large,
are not terribly successful.
The second of his traps is the
natural resource trap,
where the standard case would
be oil,
but it could be any other
commodity that is exported at
great value with--
and which can be harvested and
processed and shipped without
developing a huge economic
infrastructure,
or a nimbly functioning
internal market.
The gist of this one hinges on
what he calls Dutch disease and
the idea here is that when the
Dutch began to export North Sea
oil at great profit to their--
to the value of their currency
the inflation in the value of
the currency made their other
export products less and less
competitive and caused a kind of
lethargy in the country.
That's one piece of it.
The other piece,
which I think is actually more
important, has to do with the
relationship between democratic
rule and oil or other export
products.
If you'll look carefully at
page forty-three of Collier's
book,
he tells a story which is
actually,
it's a fairly subtle story and
I think it's a true story,
and the gist of it is that
where an economy functions
largely by exporting something
like oil,
that the impact of democratic
government on the economy is to
reduce the rate of growth.
Whereas, in economies where
that form of export production
is not important,
democratic government and the
rule of law relates to an
increasing rate of economic
growth.
His slightly smart aleck term
for this is survival of the
fattest,
and if you look at the behavior
of classic oil states,
they seem to respond to this
and once you have an
authoritarian government with an
oil export economy much of what
happens is ugly.
A good part of the ugliness we
see in Russia these days,
for example,
is made possible,
some might say inevitable,
by its powerful export
resources in petroleum and
natural gas.
The land lock trap,
and here the classic case that
will concern us will be Bolivia,
where we'll do a case two weeks
from now about trying to improve
water resources in a major
Bolivian city,
and being land locked is a bad
thing.
It's not hard to capture the
intuition of that because
commerce with distant states
historically is largely done by
marine transportation and absent
ports of your own you depend on
ports of other countries,
so that, for example,
Switzerland depends on Italian
and German ports,
and Uganda or Rwanda would
depend on Kenyan ports,
and it's probably a better idea
to depend on port systems like
those of Italy,
or Germany, than like those of
Kenya because they're far more
developed.
But there's another side to
this story,
which is that,
as Collier points out,
having rich countries for
neighbors means you have large
markets which don't require
ocean going shipping,
so that, for example,
Germany and Italy are not just
in the way of exports from
Switzerland but become markets
for those exports and breed a
great deal of wealth.
Indeed Collier shows that a 1%
increase in GDP per capita in a
neighboring state correlates
generally with about .4% of an
increase in GDP in the land
locked country.
We're almost done here.
The last one is bad states are
really bad for economies.
This one is a no-brainer.
There are two main ways for
states to be bad.
By being weak and unable to
enforce the rule of law,
tune into tonight's 6:30 world
news,
and I prophesy five days in
advance that there will be an
account of death and destruction
in Afghanistan,
where the Taliban challenged
the state for control of
territory and our soldiers try
to bring a degree of order under
almost impossible conditions;
so weak states,
failed states,
the famous case of Somalia with
its pirates would be another
case.
Iraq after the--after our
intervention was for a period a
failed state and it gives every
indication of remaining either a
failed state or a--
why don't I not prophesy about
Iraq;
I don't need to have a dog in
that fight.
The other bad government story
is kleptocracy,
and where the government or the
elites at the top of the
government use it as a means for
collecting rent from the rest of
society.
It is extraordinarily
destructive to the economy
because it takes away all the
conditions which allow people to
make investments and execute
business projects and sell
products in a sufficiently
predictable way to grow the
economy.
The other clip you're about to
see is Paul Collier himself in a
TED talk explaining,
no doubt better than I can,
what it is that The Bottom
Billion is about.
I look forward to seeing you on
Wednesday.
Paul Collier:
So can we dare to be
optimistic?
Well the thesis of The
Bottom Billion is that a
billion people have been stuck
living in economies that have
been stagnate for forty years,
and hence, diverging from the
rest of mankind.
So the real question to pose is
not "can we be
optimistic,"
it's "how can we give
credible hope to that billion
people?"
That, to my mind,
is the fundamental challenge
now of development.
What I'm going to offer you is
a recipe,
a combination,
of the two forces that changed
the world for good,
which is the alliance of
compassion and enlightened self
interest.
Compassion because a billion
people are living in societies
that have not offered credible
hope.
That is a human tragedy.
Enlightened self interest
because if that economic
divergence continues for another
forty years,
combined with social
integration globally,
it will build a nightmare for
our children.
We need compassion to get
ourselves started,
and enlightened self interest
to get ourselves serious.
That's the alliance that
changes the world.
So what does it mean to get
serious about providing hope for
the bottom billion?
What can we actually do?
Well a good guide is to think
what did we do last time the
rich world got serious about
developing another region of the
world?
That gives us,
it turns out,
quite a good clue,
except you have to go back
quite a long time.
The last time the rich world
got serious about developing
another region was in the late
1940s.
The rich world is you,
America, and the region that
needed to be developed was my
world, Europe.
It was post-war Europe.
Why did America get serious?
It wasn't just compassion for
Europe, though there was that.
It was you knew you had to,
because in the late 1940s,
country after country in
central Europe was falling into
the Soviet block,
and so you knew you had no
choice.
Europe had to be dragged into
economic development.
What did you do last time you
got serious?
Well yes, you had a big aid
program, thank you very much,
that was Marshall Aid,
we need to do it again,
and aid is part of the
solution.
But what else did you do?
Well you tore up your trade
policy and totally reversed it.
Before the war,
America had been highly
protectionist;
after the war you opened your
markets to Europe,
you dragged Europe into the
then global economy,
which was your economy,
and you institutionalized that
trade globalization through
founding the General Agreement
on Tariffs and Trade;
so total reversal of trade
policy.
Did you do anything else?
Yes, you totally reversed your
security policy.
Before the war your security
policy had been isolationist;
after the war,
you tear that up,
you put 100,000 troops in
Europe for over forty years;
so total reversal of security
policy.
Anything else?
Yes, you tear up the eleventh
commandment: national
sovereignty.
Before the war you treated
national sovereignty as so
sacrosanct that you weren't even
willing to join the League of
Nations;
after the war,
you found the United Nations,
you found the Organization for
Economic Cooperation and
Development,
you found the IMF,
you encouraged Europe to create
the European Community;
all systems for mutual
government support.
That is still the waterfront of
effective policies--aid,
trade, security,
governance.
Of course the details of policy
are going to be different
because the challenge is
different,
it's not rebuilding Europe,
and it's reversing the
divergence of the bottom billion
so that they actually catch up.
Is that easier or harder?
We need to be at least as
serious as we were then.
Now today I'm going to take
just one of those four,
I'm going to take the one that
sounds the weakest,
the one that's just motherhood
and apple pie:
governance;
mutual systems of support for
governance,
and I'm going to show you one
idea and how we could do
something to strengthen
governance,
and I'm going to show that that
is enormously important now.
The opportunity we're going to
look to is a genuine basis for
optimism about the bottom
billion, and that is the
commodity booms.
The commodity booms are pumping
unprecedented amounts of money
into many, though not all,
of the countries of the bottom
billion.
Partly they're pumping money in
because commodity prices are
high, but it's not just that;
there's also a range of new
discoveries.
Uganda has just discovered oil
at about the most disastrous
location on earth.
Ghana's discovered oil;
Guinea has got a huge new
exploitation of iron ore coming
out of the ground;
so a mass of new discoveries.
Between them,
these new revenue flows dwarf
aid.
Just to give you one example,
and gold ore alone is getting
$50 billion dollars a year in
oil revenue.
The entire aid flows to the
sixty countries of the bottom
billion last year were $34
billion,
so the flow of resources from
the commodity booms to the
bottom billion are without
precedent.
There's the optimism.
The question is how is it going
to help their development?
It's a huge opportunity for
transformation of development.
Will it be taken?
So here comes a bit of science,
and this is a bit of science
I've done since The Bottom
Billion, so it's new.
I've looked to see what is the
relationship between higher
commodity prices of exports and
the growth of commodity
exporting countries,
and I've looked globally.
I've taken all the countries in
the world for the last forty
years,
and looked to see what the
relationship is,
and so the short run--the first
five to seven years is just
great.
In fact its hunky dory,
everything goes up.
You get more money because your
terms of trade have improved,
but also that drives up output
across the board,
so GDP goes up a lot,
fantastic.
That's the short run.
How about the long run?
Come back fifteen years
later--well the short run it's
hunky dory, but the long run
it's humpty dumpty.
You go up in the short run,
but then most societies
historically have ended up worse
than if they'd had no booms at
all.
That is not a forecast about
how commodity prices go,
it's a forecast of the
consequences,
the long-term consequences for
growth of an increase in prices.
What goes wrong?
Why is there this resource
curse, as it's called?
Again, I looked at that,
and it turns out that the
critical issue is the level of
goverannce,
the initial level of economic
governance when the resource
booms accrue.
In fact, if you've got good
enough governance,
there is no resource boom.
You go up in the short term and
then you go up even more in the
long term.
That's Norway,
the richest country in Europe,
it's Australia,
and it's Canada.
The resource curse is entirely
confined to countries below a
threshold of governance.
They still go up in the short
run, that's what we see across
in the bottom billion at the
moment;
the best growth rates they've
had ever.
The question is whether the
short run will persist.
We've got governments
historically over the last forty
years;
it hasn't.
There's countries like Nigeria,
which are worse off than if
they'd never had oil.
There's a threshold level above
which you go up in the long
term, below which you go down,
just a benchmark of that
threshold.
It's about the governance level
of Portugal in the mid-1980s.
The question is,
is the bottom billion above or
below that threshold?
Now there's one big change
since the commodity booms of the
1970s, and that is the spread of
democracy.
I thought maybe that is the
thing which has transformed
governance in the bottom
billion.
Maybe we can be more optimistic
because of the spread of
democracy.
So I looked.
Democracy does have significant
effects, and unfortunately,
they're adverse.
Democracies make even more of a
mess of these resource booms
than autocracies.
At that stage I just wanted to
abandon the research,
but it turns out that democracy
is a little bit more complicated
than that,
because there are two distinct
aspects of democracy.
There's electoral competition,
which determines how you
acquire power,
and there's checks and
balances, which determine how
you use power.
It turns out that electoral
competition is the thing that's
doing the damage with democracy,
whereas strong checks and
balances makes resource booms
good.
And so what the countries of
the bottom billion need is very
strong checks and balances.
They haven't got them;
they got instant democracy in
the 1990s, elections without
checks and balances.
How can we help improve
governments and introduce checks
and balances?
In all of the societies of the
bottom billion,
there are intense struggles to
do just that.
The simple proposal is that we
should have some international
standards,
which will be voluntary,
that we should spell out the
key decision points that need to
be taken in order for it to
harness these resource revenues.
We know these international
standards work because we've
already got one.
It's called the Extractive
Industries Transparency
Initiative.
That is the very simple idea
that governments should report
to their citizens what revenues
they have.
No sooner was it proposed than
reformers in Nigeria adopted it,
pushed it, and published the
revenues in the paper.
Nigerian newspaper circulation
spiked, people wanted to know
what their government was
getting in terms of revenue.
We know it works.
What would the content be of
these international standards?
I can't go through all of them,
but I'll give you an example.
The first is how to take the
resources out of the ground.
The economic process is taking
the resources out of the ground
and putting assets on top of the
ground.
The first step in that is
selling the rights to resource
extraction.
You know how rights to resource
extraction are being sold at the
moment, how they've been sold
over the last forty years?
A company flies in,
does a deal with the minister,
and that's great for the
company and it's quite often
great for the minister,
and it's not great for the
country.
There's a very simple
institutional technology which
can transform that,
and it's called verified
auctions.
The public agency with the
greatest expertise on earth is,
of course, the treasury,
that is the British Treasury,
and the British Treasury
decided that it would sell the
rights to third generation
mobile phones by working out
what those rights were worth.
It worked out they were worth 2
billion pounds.
Just in time,
a set of economists got there
and said, "Why not try an
auction?
It'll reveal the value."
It went for 20 billion pounds
through auction.
If the British Treasury can be
out by a factor of ten,
think what the ministry of
finance in Sierra Leone is going
to be like.
When I put that out to the
president of Sierra Leone,
the next day he asked the World
Bank to send him a team to give
expertise on how to conduct
auctions.
There are five such decision
points;
each one needs an international
standard.
If we could do it,
we would change the world.
We would be helping the
reformers in these societies who
are struggling for change.
That's our modest role.
We cannot change these
societies, but we can help the
people in these societies,
who are struggling and usually
failing because the odds are so
stacked against them.
Yet, we've not got these rules.
If you think about it,
the cost of promulgating
international rules is zilch,
nothing.
Why on earth are they not there?
I realized that the reason
they're not there is that until
we have a critical mass of
informed citizens in our own
societies,
politicians will get away with
gestures;
that unless we have an informed
society what politicians do,
especially in relation to
Africa, is gestures,
things that look good but don't
work.
So I realized we had to go
through the business of building
an informed citizenry.
That's why I broke all the
professional rules of conduct
for an economist and I wrote an
economics book that you could
read on a beach.
However, I have to say,
the process of communication
does not come naturally to me,
this is why I'm on this stage,
but it's alarming.
I grew up in a culture of
self-effacement.
My wife showed me a blog
comment on one of my last talks,
and the blog comment said,
"Collier is not
charismatic,
but his arguments are
compelling."
If you agree with that
sentiment and if you agree that
we need a critical mass of
informed citizenry,
you will realize that I need
you.
Please become ambassadors.
Thank you.
Jim Alexander:
Professor Rae will be back
on Wednesday and we'll see you
then.